let's begin with fractions decimals and
percentages so this was mostly done okay
the first thing I want to point out is
question 1 B 1 B now we talked just now
in the opening review questions about
what happens when you put together two
fractions and their denominators are
different like they are in this one big
question okay now we get that they have
to have a common denominator we want
them talking the same language but a lot
of you didn't realize hey see that
one-third see the one-third right i
could rewrite one-third you can just
make out this rating here as 3 / 9 if i
multiply it top and bottom by three once
you've done that you don't need to
change the denominator of the first
fraction you can just lean it as 5 / 9
it was less work and it was quicker a
lot of you changed both denying s27
which is just extra work it added in
more places for errors to creep in so
that's why I've told you many times
mathematicians famously lazy not just
because it's efficient but because you
often get a more accurate answer if you
do less work okay so that was the first
thing turn over the page for me
this question number three this is a
question of interpretation right and
we've looked at problems like this
before you can see most of you can see
the key numbers in here thirty-six
dollars she sped twenty-five percent how
much money did she spent now see what I
just did that let me rehearse it again
look up and watch as I do I'll rehearsal
okay this is literally what I do in an
exam and I tell all of my students to do
this my senior students do it the most
as you're reading through you say
thirty-six dollars important detail
twenty-five percent important detail how
much money did she spend that's the
actual question so a lot of you got this
question wrong not because you couldn't
calculate but because you misread what
was being asked of you so bring a
highlighter into your exam bring a
colored pencil anything so you can do
just like I did and highlight the
important bits so you answer the
question correctly let's keep going this
one here r1b it did say simplify my
right as simple as possible most of you
got okay i can write g x 6 as 6g that
was good and so as a consequence you
left the answer like that happy that was
accepted but a better answer would be 5
over 2g what's the difference from one
fraction to the other one what's the
difference I've divided the top and
bottom by by three very good so fifteen
and six common common factor you might
as well take it up okay all right down
here at the bottom of the page question
to the most common error was a lot of
people read 5h right when if H is ain't
they read that is 58 right because they
are well i'm just going to replace the h
but what you need to we actually talked
about this yesterday right 5h 5h it's
short for thank you it's short for five
times H so you had to multiply that
number now this is a really important
note I want all of you every single one
even if you got these all right I want
you to also make this note under your in
your book okay we're at page three
and all the questions are of the same
style you notice at the top of the page
just says solve the equations right and
then it gives you a whole list right now
what I want you to notice is have a look
down the right-hand column of the page
okay now if there are individual
questions I will come and answer those a
bit later on I want to get all the way
through and then as people work together
they can they can answer any questions
later okay i want you to notice these
two can you see on the screen now and
it's it's warming back up stick in his
time can you see that these two here d
and e at the bottom of the page they are
different at the right hand side right
what do those numbers mean the ones and
twos Christian yeah how many marks are
assigned to each question now what we
tried to indicate to you is hey I mean
you probably could tell just by looking
at the question these ones they're a bit
harder right there a bit more difficult
okay so we expect you to take a bit more
time and will reward you more for
getting those ones correct because they
take more work okay however it also
means we're expecting you to show us how
you did the question that's right i keep
on endlessly bang your about how awesome
it important is to put working down
don't just jump to hear right what's
being assessed is actually can you
demonstrate your understanding so what
some of you may not have gotten the two
marks on this because you just jump
straight to an answer and you didn't
include can you see here on the left you
didn't include this kind of working that
showed what was going on like why why is
it m equals four well why is X equal to
ten guesser universe okay so please make
note of that you should all write that
under your notes and corrections thing
that when you see like that that number
of marks over there sometimes later on
as you get into the senior school you'll
see questions were three marks or four
marks that's a signal to you make sure
you show your working dub listen all
right over the page
okay now both of the questions at the
top of this page are worth commenting on
briefly the first one is number four if
X represents a number write an algebraic
expression to show the number increased
by four okay the important thing is that
you notice it was an expression not an
equation what's the difference between
an expression and an equation to kill +
yeah yeah perfect exactly right there's
an easy way to recognize what's what an
equation has an equal sign inner right
that's what that's what makes it an
equation so what we were just looking
for this is all your needs to say just X
plus 4 that's it their number X increase
by four that's all we were looking for
okay number five this was tricky this is
tricky required some interpretation
right the cost of a phone call is fifty
cents plus 35 cents per minute and you
get given again you might like to write
down in your own notes you got to
emphasize the important bits you get
given names prony rules for each of
these ideas here how much it costs how
long you're talking for okay you can see
how I've arrived at these bits of the
equation by reading what's in the
question can you see it tears fifty
cents you just have to pay that straight
away by the way that's often called a
flag for a lot of companies don't do
that anymore but it's still a thing an
initial cost just buy it you know
actually reading the photo the other
person picking up and then you have to
do the longer you talk as you know the
more you have to pay so you can see here
for instance if I talk for one minute
how much would they charge me for that
one minute just the one minute it's the
35 cents right plus the 50 if I talk for
two minutes there's going to be sandy
sense plus the 50 if I spoke for three
minutes it'd be a dollar dollar and five
cents plus the 50 you get the idea so
this number over here
keeps on getting bigger and bigger as
time progresses and then this guy just
kind of stays fifty cents okay so that's
what the equation would look like that
will give you the total cost okay